لقد انتهت مواجهة الحياة وأنت تنظر إلى كيفية
تأثير وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ووقت الشاشة على صحتنا جميعًا. أحب أن
تتحدث مع فتياتك عن كل هذا،
كما يمكنك مشاركة القليل معنا، لقد
كان هذا رائعًا حقًا، كما
تعلم، أعني الجميع.  يعلم أن
وقت الشاشة ربما يمثل مشكلة بالنسبة لهم
سواء كنت مراهقًا أو بالغًا فنحن
نقضي الكثير من الوقت على هواتفنا والأمر
المذهل هو أنك تبدو أن
هذه الهواتف لم تكن موجودة منذ
فترة طويلة، لذلك يبحث الكثير من الأشخاص الآن
هذه محاولة للنظر في مقدار الوقت الذي
نقضيه على الهواتف أو ما الذي يمكننا
فعله حيال ذلك. قطعة واحدة مثيرة للاهتمام من
البيانات التي قفزت في ذهني،
سيلتقط الشخص العادي هاتفه لينظر
إليه، فقط انظر إليه 300 مرة في
اليوم  أوه واو، أنت
تفعل هذا باستمرار وتكسر تلك الدورة
تلك الدورة الأولية من النظرة، لا
أعرف حتى لماذا ألتقط هاتفي،
أنا أفعل ذلك فقط، وأعتقد أنه كان
شيئًا مهمًا حقًا حدث  مرارًا
وتكرارًا، قامت كاثرين برايس، التي
ألفت كتابًا، بتأليف كتاب عن كيفية
الانفصال عن هاتفك، حيث تقول اطرح
هذه الأسئلة الثلاثة في كل مرة
تلتقط فيها هاتفك، لماذا الآن،
وماذا أيضًا، ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل
بدلاً من ذلك؟  إنه مجرد إعادة
عقلك إلى الإنترنت لثانية واحدة حتى
لا تبدأ في النظر
إلى هاتفك بلا تفكير، اعتقدت أن هذا
شيء مثير للاهتمام حقًا كنت أفعله
بالفعل في حياتي ويجب أن
أخبرك  ذكرت بناتي الثلاث، لقد أجريت
مقابلة مع بناتي الثلاث، لدي
ثلاث بنات مراهقات، هذه بعض
من أكثر المقابلات المخيفة التي
أعتقد أنني أجريتها على الإطلاق،
ولكنها سحرية أيضًا، مجرد الجلوس
هناك والتحدث مع ابنك لمدة
ساعة ونصف، لا  يعد عدم
انقطاع الهواتف أمرًا مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا
وسألت Sage من هي أكبر فتاة تبلغ من العمر
17 عامًا، هل
ستفعل الأشياء بشكل مختلف عندما تصبح بالغة
وأريدك أن تستمع إلى هذا
وسأخبرك أن ذلك كان أمرًا متواضعًا بالنسبة لي
كشخص  لأسمع أبي هذا
عندما
يكون لدي أطفال إذا
كنت لا أعتقد أنني أريد السماح لهم بالتواجد على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في وقت مبكر من عمري
وأعتقد أنني أريد
عدم تقييد ما يمكنهم الاستمرار فيه،
فأنا أريد فقط ذلك  مثل تعليمهم أن يكونوا
أكثر مسؤولية قليلاً فيما يتعلق
بكمية استخدامهم، فأنت تعرف ما يشاهدونه
ولكن مقدار
المشاهدة لأنني أعتقد أنني
أفضل كثيرًا معه الآن ولكن أعتقد أنه عندما
كنت أصغر سنًا
كنت على حسابي  الهاتف الكثير من
الحكمة من فتاة تبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا، نعم، إنه
قليلًا، نعم، من الصعب بعض الشيء
سماع ذلك لأنك تعتقد أنك
أب جيد، كما تعلم، عندما تسمح لها باستخدام
هاتفها وتقول بشكل أساسي مرحبًا،
انظر إلى الماضي، ربما كان ذلك  كان
كثيرًا وأنت تعلم أنني أعتقد أنك تعيش
وتتعلم هنا قليلاً